name with khabib and then you had Hamza
then you had Muhammad B but then not too
long ago you got added on that list yeah
exactly because I speaking out yeah it's
like a threat I think they're mostly you
know full of it but it still sucks when
you open your inbox people saying
they're going to come and kill you they
don't want some of the Truth Exposed I
think Israel only survives through a lie
you know or I think at this point
they've been there long enough or people
would be happy if they did a real
two-state solution but I think they want
to continue taking all the all that land
it's such a weird thing how they write
names of missile or they write like
taunts on missiles they'll bring Israeli
School children to ride on missiles and
they'll go bomb Palestinian children
with it it's just such a such a sick
thing they do